George and Amal continue their red
carpet rain in Hollywood and I had a
front row ticket
Mrs Clooney
it was George's Premiere but he was all
about Amal who wore vintage Alexander
McQueen from 2003.
she has a pretty nice taste yeah she
really does
the other Leading Lady in George's life
is of course Julia Roberts when she
crashed our interview things got silly
she's wearing heels I'm not that yeah
yeah yeah but do you see what I'm doing
too I'm doing this oh that's nice of you
we used to be married married worse 19
years of my life George and Julia Star
as a divorced couple trying to stop
their daughter's wedding in their new
rom-com ticket to Paradise the movie
hits theaters Friday but we here it's
one of George's Classics that Julia
really loves I understand that Julia has
you saved in her phone as Batman yeah
that's gonna change is it me Michael
Keaton's coming back could you ever Dawn
the suit again well I think there'd be a
protest on you I think there would be a
oh yes there it actually would be a
protest but I think that there's a real
uh a calling for once you know like in
about 30 years
when I'm sort of even smaller yeah
if you're Batman in her phone what's
Brad Pitt in yours
[Music]